the foreign affairs select committee has
been hearing from an official who says
the response to the situation of kabul
was chaotic and has suggested that you
yourself intervened to try and get the
nausea animals out
and they got priority over some afghan
people did you intervene that way no
that's complete nonsense but what i can
tell you is that i think that the
operation of pitting to to to earlier 15
000 uh people out of kabul uh in the way
that we did over the summer was one of
the outstanding military achievements of
the uh of the last 50 years or more and
i think that the role of the foreign
office the role of the uh of uh of
border force everybody involved in it
the home office officials they did an
absolutely outstanding job processing
very very difficult very complex claims
incredibly uh incredibly quickly and of
course sometimes decisions uh took
hours longer than we wanted to but you
know you have to be careful about how
you do it it was still an astonishing
thing to get fifteen thousand people
ever airlifted out of of kabul in pretty
harrowing circumstances and of course as
you know uh we we continue to have the
afghan resettlement scheme to help
people to whom we owe obligations and
who may be leaving afghanistan in fear
of their lives